I had a chance to speak with director
patty Jenkins about her new film what
makes a female superhero different than
a male superhero a lot of folks who have
come before I've said the problem is
when you try and make a female superhero
just like a male superhero yeah I agree
but the thing about Wonder Woman which
is very feminine and definitely
different is that her objective is to
bring love and truth to mankind it's not
to stop any specific villain and it's
not to fight and it's not to stop crime
she'll do all of those things in such a
badass way you can't believe it to
defend you and so it's an interesting
other thing that brings that moral
perspective into it in the game yeah
morality and femininity are issues that
patty Jenkins has explored before
monster the 2003 film she wrote and
directed about serial killer Aileen
Wuornos you forgive wisdom earn Charlize
Theron the Oscar for Best Actress and it
ultimately put Jenkins in the running
for her dream project I grew up very
inspired by Superman 1 and by kind of
the promise of like the genre of what a
superhero origin story can do and so
when Hollywood started asking me what I
wanted to do I couldn't believe nobody
had made Wonder Woman get past that and
then boom nearly a decade passed before
the film was hers to make what went
through your mind when the door opened
it's two things it's a little bit like
once you've thought about something for
so long it feels strangely normal on the
one hand on the other hand the surrey
ality of I can't believe we're getting
to make Wonder Woman and also oh my god
we have to make the greatest Wonder
Woman of all time the future superhero
known as Diana is born into a tribe of
female warriors as daughter of their
queen she is groomed for battle under
the watchful eye of her aunt you expect
a battle to be fair Robin Wright says
there was a lot of estrogen on set yeah
there was I'm assuming the added thing
there were moments where I was standing
on a beach and
150 women were about to comic-con horses
and fight on a beach and I did have
moments of saying my god also because I
we've hand-picked like the most badass
interesting women from around the world
so it was wild I'm going mother if you
choose to leave it may never return how
would I be a feisty
Diana leaves the island in search of
Ares the God of War you mean you were
lying I'm a spy that's what I do
guided by an American spy working for
British intelligence in the middle of
the first world war what was it like for
the men on set I mean Chris Pine isn't a
lot of scenes where he's surrounded by
women who are showing him what to do
yeah he's definitely playing the reverse
role of not the one leading the story
necessarily all Civic but then also cool
because he is playing such a heroic role
to watch that become so subtle and
beautiful stay here I'll go ahead
because in a way it's more heroic and
it's not unlike like an Indiana Jones or
something I was like look this is all I
have
I've got human skills if you can do that
I'm gonna get over my sexism right now
say why don't you go do that
inspired by the feminist movement writer
William Marston created Wonder Woman in
1941 the character has been featured in
comic books and a live-action TV show
starring Lynda Carter but she has not
been without controversy Wonder Woman is
a feminist icon in yeah of ways but the
same time she's wearing this kind of
skimpy sexy outfit yeah some people say
you can't have both
what's yes monster that I think that
that's sexist
I think it's sexist to say you can't
have both I have to ask myself what I
would apply to any other superhero this
is fantasy and it's not for anyone other
than the person having the fantasy I is
a little girl like took a huge amount of
delight in the idea that for my power
and my ability to stop that bully on
that playground I could also look like
Lynda Carter while I was doing it like
her heroine Jenkins has faced
significant barriers she's only the
third woman to direct a film with a
budget of at least 100 million dollars
and the first woman to direct a
superhero film but she hasn't let the
pressure distract her I'm too busy
looking at the more important duty that
got handed to me which is to make the
best Wonder Woman film and are you the
right director who thinks to try sure
okay go I definitely feel pressure
I just couldn't you can't think about
all the variables trickle-down effect
that will that is it's also representing
still Jenkins knows that Hollywood will
be putting Wonder Woman's box-office
performance under extra scrutiny women
directors often get judged by the
performance of previous women direct Oh
big-time that doesn't happen for men in
Hollywood no why is that because we're
still in the very place that this movie
is trying to work against I want to make
a great superhero film not a great woman
superhero film similarly I want to be a
great director not a great woman
director but at the moment the world is
still preoccupied with the fact that I'm
a woman director that's the struggle is
it changing at all I don't know I
honestly don't know
I feel interestingly that the director
in me wants this film that I made to
succeed but the person who's not me at
all whose lives inside of me whose
outside of me is like
heard people say for many years Oh
nobody would go see a female superhero
film women don't like action all those
things that part of me is watching
saying let's prove them wrong while
there is plenty of interest from both
sexes you should know that a couple
movie theaters are doing women only
screenings I heard about very
controversial but I really hope this
film does well I do too no pressure
that's a big moment for her and for that
and for Wonder Woman